voilà un trou de rat ça dure ça fait
deux mois et demi et personne qui a fait
quelque chose
[Musique]
mais ils m'ont temps est l'un des
quartiers de l'est parisien les plus
populaires pas pour longtemps peut-être
ici les familles à revenus modestes ont
de plus en plus de difficultés à se
loger les immeubles qui les abritent
sont rachetés soit par des sociétés
privées soit par la Ville de Paris
souvent détruit parfois réhabilité ces
immeubles sont transformés par les
promoteurs privés en bureaux en
logements de standing et par la Ville de
Paris en beau très beau logement sociaux
aménilmontant ce foyer de trois
personnes vit dans un logement de 12
mètres carrés revenus mensuel 10000
francs depuis 10 ans ils attendent en
vain un logement social
ça fait 13 ans qu'on habite dans cet
appartement et ça fait 10 ans que j'ai
fait une demande légale pour changer
pour trouver un appartement un peu plus
confortable je travaille à la ville de
Paris la seule proposition qu'on m'a
fait c'était en banlieue mais par
rapport à mon point de travail les
transports
toujours sur une liste d'attente et
comme étant donné qu'on n'est pas
prioritaire alors on attend et pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas prioritaire parce qu'on
a pas d'enfant voisin et puis malgré
qu'on a aucun confort ici on a ni
toilette ni salle de bain ni enfin on a
juste les services plus enfin le
toilettes publiques sur le palier le
soir vous dormez avec votre fils dans la
même pièce
ça serait une idéale si on avait une
chambre chacun
puis ça dépend aussi des loyers aussi
est-ce qu'il nous semble qu'il y aurait
des logements pour vous dans le quartier
quand on voit toute quartier tout ce qui
s'est construit autour bien sûr qu'il y
avait pas mal de logements
mais je sais pas on attend
et pourtant à deux pas de cet
appartement tout un quartier de
logements sociaux construit ou commandé
par l'office HLM de la ville de Paris
depuis quelques temps il n'est pas rare
d'apercevoir des vigiles en faction
chargé d'éloigner d'éventuelles familles
squatteurs ils surveille jour et nuit
pendant des mois des immeubles HLM ou
les appartements vides ne manquent pas
ce qu'on a pu remarquer d'un petit peu
étrange c'est que depuis cette mois la
plupart des appartements sont encore
vides c'est encore inoccupé on doit être
à peu près cinq ou six familles habitées
ici pour l'instant pourquoi voulez-vous
qu'un organisme social quel qu'il soit
laisse des logements vacants ils
perdrait des loyers d'abord or le
financement de ces logements sociaux
c'est très difficile et il y a des
milliers de gens qui attendent un
logement ce serait totalement absurde
alors je dément formellement l'existence
de ces fameux logements libres
le logement libre peut-être attend-il
s des prisons les prioritaires
peuplement ou des gens qui ont été
expulsés d'un logement où il y a eu un
arrêté de péril où il y a une opération
que vous rappeliez tout à l'heure deux
Zac on doit démolir un immeuble pour en
construire d'autres voilà les quelques
cas super prioritaires auxquels nous
devons faire face tous les jours
alors pourquoi le pack office public
d'aménagement et construction dépendant
de la ville de Paris propriétaire depuis
deux ans de cet hôtel meublé laisse-t-il
croupir plus de 140 personnes immigrées
salariés dont au moins une quarantaine
d'enfants 140 personnes toutes
prioritaires que le pack doit également
rejet en attendant chaque famille a reçu
un avis d'expulsion une autre obligation
légale qui permettrait à relogement de
ces familles faire déclarer cet immeuble
en péril échappant à toute norme
minimale de sécurité il n'est toujours
pas frappé d'un arrêté de péril voilà un
trou de rat ça dure ça fait deux mois et
demi et personne qui a fait quelque
chose
et maintenant c'est les doigts les
toilettes qu'on est condamnés par les
toilettes trois toilettes et maintenant
si on a envie de y aller aux toilettes
il faut sortir dehors
et mon enfant qui circule dans le
couloir plusieurs fois et là j'ai peur
ils ont démoli ici et ce qui paraît ils
ont dit qu'ils vont nous ils vont faire
un logement ici pour nous reloger et
détruire ici mais on attend toujours il
y a rien on n'a jamais eu de réponse
jamais l'Office à chanam il y a personne
qui se dépasse pour nous
cette femme a toutes les raisons de
s'inquiéter si l'on en croit ce tracte
du secrétaire de l'OPAC Henri de Lesquin
également président du Club de l'Horloge
SOS
identité aujourd'hui l'identité de la
France est menacée l'emploi l'école le
logement et la sécurité sociale sont
malades d'une immigration incontrôlée la
campagne antiraciste actuelle est en
réalité antinationale et outrageante
pour les Français nous vous laissons
deviner le sans réservé dans cette
office public aux candidat locataires
qui ne correspondent pas à l'idéal de
Monsieur Henry de Lesquen
dans un rapport datant de 1989 la Cour
des comptes s'inquiétait du nombre
croissant de logements vacants dans le
parc de l'office HLM de Paris elle
constatait d'autre part que plus de 60%
des locataires installés depuis moins de
5 ans présentaient des revenus
supérieurs aux 80% du plafond
réglementaire
sur fond de spéculation immobilière
beaucoup de Parisiens cadres moyens ou
supérieur sont alors exclus d'un marché
locatif privé exorbitant il se tourne
vers le logement social
quand on demande à des gens quatre fois
le prix du loyer en revenu on imagine
aisément qu'un logement de ce type là
3000 francs de loyer multipliés par 4 ça
fait 12000 francs on est plus en train
de loger les couches populaires les
couches populaires ne gagnent pas 12000
francs les couches populaires se
retrouveront forcément en banlieue si
aucun coup d'arène est mis à ça parce
que pour des raisons de surface
d'appartement en fonction du nombre
d'enfants et pour les raisons de revenus
que je viens de décrire annonce
strictement pas les moyens d'avoir accès
au logement social et parfois même on ne
prend même pas leur inscriptions dans
les mairies actuellement à Paris
je les exclus du logement social parfois
la résistance s'organise comme sur la
place de la Réunion dans le 20e
arrondissement ou 48 familles comme
toujours et fermement on attend d'un
logement quelques propositions mais
toujours en banlieue c'est ainsi qu'à
Saint-Denis sur le parc de logement dont
il est propriétaire l'office HLM de
Paris à magnanimement proposé à quelques
familles devenir s'installer dans la
cité des deux couronnes une cité de
transit construite en 1960 devenu au fil
des années un habitat définitif problème
l'office HLM venait justement de signer
avec la mairie de Saint-Denis une
convention de destruction reconstruction
de cette cité aussi tous les logements
vides étaient murés courues du maire de
Saint-Denis et désenchantement des
habitants la mairie de sa nuit est venue
papa parce que c'était mal fait parce
que ça leur plaisait pas que c'était
émuré et qu'il mettait des gens de Paris
alors vous qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
quand ils ont des muré ces appartements
à la construction s'est terminée
moi ça fait 29 ans que je suis là je me
suis dit bah on est encore parti pour
une dizaine d'années parce que c'est
bien douté qu'il ferait plus rien en
réouvrant les les logements ici des
appartements condamnés muret sans eau
sans gaz sans chauffage casse la tienne
le fils à HLM tel un squatteur habitué
des murs repeints et installe en 48
heures eau froide et électricité pour le
gaz et le chaude mieux vaudra patienter
enfin en toute cohérence l'office HLM
parisien annule et renie son contrat de
réhabilitation
on voudrait quelque chose ça fait 30 ans
que que la cité n'a pas été rénovée il y
a rien qui a été fait juste pour les
squators je trouve ça un peu dégueulasse
alors qu'il pense un peu à nous à nous
les gens qui qui sont là depuis 30 ans
[Musique]